let's turn now to efforts to roll out
the vaccine on a global scale should we
and joining us is anil sonny here chief
exec of the world health organization
foundation hello t thank you so much for
joining us on the program this morning
uh what more does the developed world
need to do to help those less fortunate
well thank you kay for having me
the the developed world needs to follow
through on its pledges to donate doses
and to ensure that the governments of
low-income countries have support doses
funding technical support to roll out
vaccines currently less than five
percent of the population of low-income
countries has been vaccinated vaccine
inequity is morally unjust it's also
epidemiologically and economically
self-defeating so it's in all of our
interest to ensure that everyone is
vaccinated
isn't that what kovacs is for
exactly kovacs is delivering vaccines
around the world in fact kovacs has
contracts for 3.7 billion vaccines only
500 million have been delivered wealthy
countries have promised to donate 1.4
billion doses but less than 200 million
have been delivered we want to create
the ability for everyone to use their
voice and their wallet to contribute uh
people-powered vaccines can be an
important motivator to elected
representatives the who foundation
created the campaign go give one go give
one.org where you can give 4 quid and
buy a vaccine for someone else and show
that you are willing to do what you want
your government to do which is to follow
through on its commitments to donate
vaccines through kovacs
so i i put this to the government
minister this morning i don't know if
you heard him or not but he was
basically saying there was a big fire as
we know um in india
earlier on in the year and as a result
there aren't enough vaccines to go
around at the moment
i don't believe that's true
there are more than 800 million excess
doses in high income countries across
the g7 including the uk that is a lot of
doses that can be distributed are there
enough doses to vaccinate everyone in
the world not necessarily but there are
enough doses to vaccinate just as many
people in low-income countries as in
high income countries we have the
vaccines now what we need to do is
follow through in our promise to deliver
them and make sure that people have
access
how disappointed are you with the
british government
i am
proud as someone who spent 20 years
working on hiv aids that in such a short
period of time in this pandemic we've
developed vaccines and delivered them to
more than three and a half billion
people i am incredibly disappointed in
everyone any government and any leader
who has facilitated the inequity such
that people who are in high income
countries including myself and my family
have access we are privileged we are
protected i am grateful for that
the fact that my family and relatives
and other parts of the world don't have
access
that's a tragedy and we should all be
held accountable for that
including the british government
indeed any government that can do more
that isn't
okay one in two people in high-income
countries i believe have been vaccinated
we talk about low-income countries it
falls to one in 13 people
what impact is that vaccine inequality
actually having in real terms
it breeds variance it also causes
massive economic damage it's in our
interest our self-interest to ensure
that everyone is vaccinated the world is
a petri dish when you have a population
that's well vaccinated but another
population that's not it's in that
population of people that is not well
vaccinated that you have variants that's
where they emerge and variance risk
reducing the efficacy of the existing
vaccine and also it has massive economic
damage trillions of dollars is what it's
going to cost high-income countries the
uk europe the united states because
low-income countries don't have high
vaccine coverage rates the world health
organization had set a target of 70
percent of the the world the globe to be
vaccinated by the middle of next year is
that still within reach
if we act we're certainly not on track
today the interim target was to reach 40
percent of the world by the end of 2021.
it's december 2nd that's days weeks away
we have to do much more much more
quickly in order to keep that 70 percent
target alive and real
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for taking the time
much appreciated thank you